faut pas jouer sur les mots ou bien on
prolonge l'état d'urgence parce que la
situation sanitaire le justifie ou bien
on le prolonge pas on n'est pas dans un
entre-deux ni dans un en même temps en
réalité le gouvernement j'ai vu son
texte il est public depuis ce matin ils
renvoient expressément aux dispositions
de l'état d'urgence pour la liberté
d'aller et venir pour la fermetures
éventuelles d'établissements qui
reçoivent du public pour l'organisation
des transports collectifs pour
l'interdiction de certaines
manifestations
autrement dit nous dit l'alliance année
plus de l'état d'urgence moi je lui
réponds bah c'est quand même de l'état
d'urgence alors toute la question et
l'état d'urgence là il fera débat entre
nous ce sera d'assumer par leur nom les
choses si l'on doit poursuivre l'état
d'urgence il faut que la situation
sanitaire le justifie et sinon on ne
poursuit pas l'état d'urgence mais on
sait que on a le droit de le remettre en
place par un simple décret du
gouvernement du jour au lendemain
donc nous allons travailler sur cette
question nous allons entendre les
informations scientifiques sur l'état de
l'épidémie et nous verrons bien à ce
moment là ce que nous déciderons mais en
tout cas nous prendrons une décision
franche pas dans un entre deux